俺の人生にバーニングポイント
もうすることはないでしょう
まあ俺は今まで数々のヘリコプターを飛ばしてきた俺の家で。
2回くらいですね
数々ではないです
2回ラジコンヘリ飛ばしたんですけども
まあどれもこう上手くいかない感じで終わってるんですよ
でも今日はね
今日は一味違うぜ
今日はねもうね俺は失敗すること許されないからね
ちょっと...ガチもんを持ってきました
でかっ！
ジャイアントⅡということで
まあ見てもらってわかると思うんですけども
バカデカいです　なんかね
115cmのビッグサイズ
これがね多分お店で一番大きかったです
これが多分最強です
今日はこの最強サイズのヘリコプターを
まあ家で飛ばそうと思います
まあデカければいいってもんなんだよ
いやそういうわけではないと思うけども
だけどデカい方がいいじゃん
安定しそうだしね
いかつ（厳つい）
はい　こんな感じです
取り付け方法が書いてありますね
なるほどなるほど
すげー
全然わかりません
ちゃんと色々説明してあるので多分
なんとかなるでしょう！
1番　本体のテールシャフトの接続コードの端子　赤　白　それぞれの色別れる＆＆＄’＆’（％＆（％’
あ、これはできそうだ
くそったれが！
あ、針金だらけだ
本体のテールシャフトの接続コードと端子をそれぞれ合わせて接続します
なるほどなるほど
なんとなくわかったゾ
とりあえずこれをくっ付けなきゃいけないってことか
固定棒
こいつらを使うのか
これか！
なんかエロいね
これでいいんだな？
俺知らないゾ？
固定されているはずです
は？ふざけんなよ！まじで　どうやってやるの？
無理無理無理
来た来た来た来た
もう終わります
とりあえず待て、、、一回動くかどうか確かめよう
動くかどうかだけを確認してみよう
これで果たして動くかどうかだな
いけるから一回ちゃんと付けます
飛べるわ　ちゃんと充電します
もしかしてだけど　もしかしてだけど　もしかしてだけど今回はじめのヘリ飛べるんじゃないの～？
もしかしてだけどもしかしてだけど母さんに怒られるんじゃないの～？
よしOK　完成です
よし準備完了だよバディー
鼻をかみたいよバディー
さあ皆さん大変長らくおまたせしました
いよいよ超巨大ヘリを飛ばす時が来たってわけなんで
まあぱぱっとっと行っちゃいましょうこんなの
everyone OK?
右OK 左OK
画面OK
来いや
家でやる物じゃない